God has given me this story fat people
that are also backup dancers that are
also fighting with their fat boss about
who was made to eat a vagina a banana
out of a vagina this is my favorite
Story of the Year at what point did you
realize that what you were experiencing
what led you experienced was not normal
um I
it's hard to answer that question
because as this was my first
professional job I was told by the dance
captain and you know
um just yeah no one had hired me no one
had hired me before because I'm a fat
slob
I don't know that's really difficult to
uh talk about see I'd never had a dance
job before uh by looking at me you can
tell that I'm not a dancer in any way
shape or form